when some kids are busy playing sports
are playing online games these kids
decided to make better use of their time
proving that hard work and a little
innovation can go a long way in a short
time if you are a first-time viewer
click the red subscribe button and enjoy
today we are discussing 10 amazing kids
who became self-made millionaires Murad
a thief wala known as one of the most
promising entrepreneurs of our time
farhad acid wala
started making a name for himself at the
young age of 16 you may recognise a
koala from his TED talks about his
company Roxanne media acid wala started
his company which is a marketing agency
at just 16 years old and it now has more
than 20 employees globally he credits
his employees for being the reason he is
so successful but we are sure his
innovation and motivation has something
to do with it Harvey Millington with
some quick thinking and smart investment
14-year old Harvey Millington was able
to make himself a millionaire he was
gifted $2,000 from his father and used
to invest in a car tax this company who
started the company ended up making a
$100,000 profit and with that money
Bettina invested $40,000 in a plot of
land news parent home not long after his
land purchased when developers offered
million two million dollars for the lens
he realized this deal was too good to
pass up and accepted a two million
dollar offer and is now one of the UK's
youngest self-made millionaires Isabella
Barrett she may be the youngest
millionaire on this list but that timing
means she has even more time to make
millions Isabella Barrett is a nine year
old exhales in tiaras star and she's
already worth millions
the young ex pageant cleaned his
millions of online followers and is
considered a successful businesswoman in
her own right Barrett has been able to
use her social media influence to start
to fashion brands named glitzy girls and
bound by the crown Couture not only did
she help develop the brand but she is
also a stakeholder in both companies she
is now predicted to be as big as the
Olsen twins were in the 90s Nick
Selvaggio McDowell wasseo had his mind
set on making millions before he even
reached puberty by the age of 15 de la
geo had already taught himself how to
code and he's developing apps during his
break he was able to cash in on his
talents and he developed the app trim it
which helps trim down Lane B new
articles a Japanese investors saw the
potential of the app and gave de la CEO
$300,000 in venture capital such
effective they went on to sell the end
product some lead to Yahoo for 30
million dollars John [ __ ] John [ __ ] from
a young age understood the importance of
making a profit and thinking outside the
box when he was 16 he noticed New York
City was missing something so we open
NYC's first auto parts business he
serves started making millions and was
even the main distributor of parts to
the MTV show pimp my ride
not wanting to limit himself to the auto
market [ __ ] tried his hand in fashion
when he launched a fashion line with
rapper Young Jeezy who made millions
more with the fashion line and stepped
to make billions
Ashley Qualls proving that girls have a
place in the coding world Ashley Qualls
taught himself how to code HTML when she
was 14 she thought of it as an art and
to get more attention for her art she
launched a site called whatever life's
calm which showcased her work after
helping her friends design their myspace
profiles ersite started getting some
real traction Wells decided to take
advantage of the numbers by joining
Google Adsense where she got a cut of
advertising revenue she eventually went
on to cut her own deals with advertisers
and sell brings and millions from
whatever life.com Atom Hildreth not only
was Adam Hill dress a millionaire by 16
but he also went on to use his money to
help other team he'll dress first struck
gold with his social networking sites
double which was popular in the UK with
the money from his first site he founded
and developed a company named crisp
which is used to help protect kids from
online predators the dress was so
successful that he made the top 20 list
of UK's welcome esteemed Robert nay
Robert nay could have never predicted
that he would earn his millions in the
span of two weeks and at the age of 14
after ney developed and released a
smartphone game called bubble ball it
made two million dollars in just two
short weeks the game was so popular it
went on to have over 16 million
downloads
after his success mate founded his
company may gain core he still continues
to develop new games and apt this proves
that even overnight successes still have
to work hard to keep their millions
mikaila Ulmer when mikaila Ulmer started
studying bees at the age of five she
noticed that they were starting to
disappear worried about this she decided
to start her own lemonade company using
her grandmother's 1940s recipes the
catch is that she sweetened the lemonade
with honey not sugar like her
competitors Almer also donates portions
of her company's revenue to beat rescue
foundation in 2015 after appearing on
ABC network's Shark Tank the now eleven
year old secured and eleven million
dollar deal with for food the market
will now distribute her lemonade
regionally with the potential to go
nationwide Shubham Banerjee after
realizing scope of visually impaired
people with the lack of access to
Braille printers thirteen-year-old
Chubin Banerjee took matters into his
own hands wanting people who read and
Braille to have better access to Braille
printers Banerjee designed a Braille
printer out of Legos the printer was so
impressive it caught the eye of Intel
who invested millions into the printer
Banerjee now owns a multi-million dollar
company Borrego labs Inc and still works
on trying to find cost-effective
solutions for the Braille printer do
these kids who became self-made
millionaires impress you react in the
comments section below and don't forget
to like this video and subscribe to the
things